[Music]
Israel caught off guard after the
largest and deadliest escalation of
violence in decades tonight rockets and
air strikes continue to rain down on
Israel and Gaza after a day of shock
death and
destruction that's the Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu declared
claring war against Hamas good evening
and thank you for joining us at dawn
local time Hamas militants launched an
unprecedented and large scale surprise
attack targeting dozens of locations in
Israel right now Israeli authorities say
at least 200 people in Israel have been
killed the Gaza Health Ministry says 232
Palestinians are dead gunman stormed
across Israel's Southern border near the
Gaza Strip on foot and by air using
motorized paragliders to sweep into
several border towns taking soldiers and
civilians hostage Joel senic begins our
coverage tonight and we want to warn you
our reporting contains images that may
be
disturbing without warning violence and
Chaos erupts in the Middle
East the Palestinian militant group
Hamas striking Israel with thousands of
rockets and sending groups of gunmen
across the border the surprise early
Saturday morning attack taking place
during one of the holiest weekends on
the Jewish
calendar a stunned Israel now declaring
war and vowing to inflict what prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu calls an
unprecedented
price I have ordered an extensive
mobilization of reserves and that we
return fire of a magnitude that the
enemy has not
known we are at War and we will win
it hamas's military leader says the
assault is in response to the blockade
of Gaza Israeli raids inside the West
Bank and violence at a disputed holy
site Israeli forces striking back
flattening a high-rise building in Gaza
City and mobilizing troops across the
country at one point Security Forces
said there were almost two dozen ongoing
gun battles very scary situation um you
know many people have died already and
we hear about people being kidnapped
video from Hamas appears to show its
Fighters inside Israeli Army Camps a
spokesperson for the group says it's
holding dozens of Israeli soldiers
captive while Israel says Hamas also has
civilian
hostages Reuters releasing this video
which appears to show the moment one of
those captives was taken back into Gaza
in Washington President Joe Biden
condemning the attacks in a rare
Saturday address saying saying he spoke
by phone with prime minister Netanyahu
and let there be no mistake the United
States stands with the state of Israel
the US defense secretary is also in
contact with his Israeli counterpart
saying he will work to ensure Israel has
the support it needs with no timeline
for the end of this conflict Joel senic
Global News
Washington like several other Global
Airlines Air Canada's moving temporarily
to cancel its flights to Tel Aviv
starting on Sunday of course in a
response to these attacks the carrier
says it's going to be monitoring the
situation and it will adjust flights
accordingly the United Nations Security
Council is going to be holding an
emergency meeting tomorrow on the
situation with the UN Secretary General
Antonio Gutierrez contemning today's
attack and voicing his deep concern for
the civilians that have been caught in
the conflict T isra has more on how
Canada is responding alongside the
International
Community the surprise attacks stunned
Israel and the world setting off Swift
condemnation from Western leaders
including prime minister Justin Trudeau
he tweeted Canada strongly condemns the
current terrorist attacks against Israel
we stand with Israel and fully support
its right to defend itself opposition
leader Pierre POV also tweeted I
unequivocally condemn the invasion of
Israel by Hamas terrorists and the
sadistic violence they have subsequently
carried out against innocent civilians
we are facing a horrendous terrorist
attack that has really no precedent I
think in our origion or in the history
British prime minister Rishi sunak
expressed his shock so did Britain's
foreign secretary and the UK completely
condemns these terrorist acts against
Israel and we support Israel's right to
self-defense president of the European
Union commission Ursula Vander liion
called the Hamas incursion pure
terrorism
terroris French leader Emanuel macron
discussed the situation with the prime
minister of Israel and the president of
the Palestinian Authority and pledged
his commitment to Israel's
security a stark contrast to the scenes
unfolding in tan celebrations erupted in
the streets after the carefully
coordinated attack by Hamas which is
backed by the Iranian regime next door
in Turkey president erdogan pleaded for
restraint
urging all sides to avoid being
impulsive and heightening tensions the
Turks have recently warmed ties with
Israel so have the Saudis who are in
negotiations brokered by the US to
normalize relations with the Israeli
government in a statement the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia renewed its calls for a
two-state solution and says it made
repeated warnings of the dangers as a
result of the continued occupation and
the deprivation of Palestinian people
and their legitimate rights Palestinian
leaders say for too long the conflict
has been ignored the world Community has
done nothing to stop an occupation that
has become the longest in modern history
the United Nations is urging maximum
restraint appealing to both sides to
deescalate and stop further
Bloodshed teria isri Global News
Ottawa Benjamin Netanyahu is Israel's
longest serving prime minister and over
his 16 years in office he's faced
numerous flareups and violence with
Palestinian militants a Cascade of
Elections serious legal battles and
chaotic Street protests but as Redmond
Shannon reports this could be the
greatest crisis Netanyahu has ever had
to deal
with addressing the Nation Saturday
night prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
promised Mighty Vengeance against Hamas
it is almost exactly 50 years since
Israel's longest serving prime minister
served in the yam kapor War a conflict
that caught Israel off guard now as
prime minister he is dealing with what
appears to be another massive
intelligence
failure events never before seen since
the foundation of Israel the Hamas
Invasion killings and kidnapping of
Israelis comes in a year that Netanyahu
is dealing with waves of disrup itive
protests against judicial
reforms his critics alleging the
proposals erode the independence of
Israel's Judiciary Netanyahu is also
facing ongoing trials for bribery and
fraud and he is steering the country's
most right-leaning coalition government
ever opposition leader y Leed says he
will put aside the bitter differences
and take up netanyahu's offer to form an
emergency the unity government the real
problem for Benyamin Netanyahu is not
the near term there's a lot of unanimity
in Israel on what to do in the near term
the real problem is going to come in two
three four weeks time when the Israelis
try to figure out what's the end state
of this conflict previous hostage
situations in the region have played out
for months or even years the longer it
drags on the louder the dissenting
voices will become Netanyahu has been
attacked on his right and his left for
his entire career and that doesn't
really face him that's just the nature
of Life Netanyahu is fighting for his
political survival as he always does
this unprecedented crisis will likely
test Netanyahu like never before Redmond
Channon Global News
London for more now on what these latest
escalations could mean Cliff kupchan
joins us now he's the chairman of the
Eurasia group appreciate you joining us
Cliff first I want to ask you Benjamin
Netanyahu says Hamas will pay a huge
price so what what's
next it's going to be very hard for the
Prime Minister not to do something that
Israel's avoided doing for 20 years
going into the Gaza Strip a land War
dismantling hamas's operational
capability taking down as much as
hamas's leadership as he can that's not
necessarily next but that's a major
escalation that I think we're on the
cusb as we
speak you know a lot of people are
wondering how Israeli Defense Forces
were off guard so how did this
happen I think Israel's had a national
two national preoccupations I would say
first the battle over clipping the wings
of the Supreme Court so that Mr
Netanyahu gets all sorts of new powers
second less out less in the headlines
the Israeli Defense Forces have really
been concentrating on the West Bank and
it may be the case that we learn soon
that they've taken their eye off the
South and that vulnerability has been
exploited you know rather adly adroitly
unfortunately by Hamas but that still
doesn't get to the question of as you
started what we do next and that's a
real problem okay do we know who was
helping Hamas and if so how big could
this
get well that's The $64,000 Question you
know the big 800lb elephant looming in
the background of all of this is Iran
Iran is
hamas's most significant major
Patron Iran is the one that if it is has
been involved in planning this if it
continues to this we got to watch this
really carefully if Iran provides arms
to Hamas as this war develops and
continues and third if Hezbollah another
one of Iran's Patriots joins the war and
opens the second front then we got a big
problem because if Iran indeed has its
fingerprints all over this then Israel
is going to be very tempted to hit
Iranian bases per se in Iran and then
Off to the Races then we got a much
wider War then we could have Iran and
its allies attacking Israel and then
what does the US do so don't want to get
ahead of the game here but that's what
I'm really watching to see if this
spreads and becomes a geopolitical you
know
Firestorm Cliff kchan the chairman of
the Eurasia group thanks so much for
joining us it's my pleasure thank
you we'll have more on the situation in
the Middle East later on in the program
but we're going to turn to other news of
the day in Afghanistan hundreds are
feared dead after a pair of powerful
earthquakes crumbled buildings near the
Iranian border severe damage could be
seen near the city of harat after a 6.3
magnitude Quake struck the region
followed by a powerful 5.5 magnitude
Aftershock local authorities estimate
about 120 people were killed with more
than a thousand others said to be
injured those figures are expected to
rise as the race is now on to find
people who are trapped under the
rubble here at home calls are growing
for the expansion of a new weapon to
fight illness as cold and flu season
kicks off last month Health Canada
approved a vaccine for RSV for adults
aged 60 and older doctors say this shot
is a GameChanger but they also worry
that many seniors won't be able to
afford it health reporter Katherine Ward
explains respiratory sensial virus can
have devastating outcomes I've seen a
number of patients unfortunately die um
in our hospitals every year we know that
thousands people are dying every year
mostly older people from this virus Dr
Samir sin is thrilled shots for seniors
will go into arms this fall however he
warns a patchwork of publicly funded
coverage will undermine the vaccine's
effectiveness unfortunately it's not
covered for for um for most older
Canadians at the moment it then comes up
to the provinces to make a determination
as to whether they're going to cover
this uh or not uh and how they will
allow it to be administered Ontario has
chosen to publicly fund the vaccine for
people 60 and older living in most
congregate care settings other provinces
say they are awaiting federal guidelines
before determining whether they will
follow suit in BC the cost for an RSV
vaccine is roughly
$230 experts say some private insurance
plans will cover the cost of getting a
RSV vaccine further guidance from nassie
isn't expected until next fall if you
don't have coverage by the provincial
health plan that you're in then it's
going to be up to you to see if you can
afford to keep yourself healthy and that
is absolutely not what we want for
vaccines Advocates say it's important
older Canadians are not forgotten we
haven't done a good job keeping track of
how common this is and how prevalent it
is um we've continued to under recognize
the burden in older adults you would
think with coid 19 that we would take
vaccines really seriously and that
governments would want to fund all all
nzi recommended vaccines but it hasn't
been the case Katherine Ward Global News
Toronto Paris being plagued by pests
coming up frustration in the City of
Lights now swarmed by bed
bugs Paris may be known as the city of
flights but the French capital is also
earning a new reputation due to a
growing problem the French Capital
struggling with a surge and bed bug
infestation in both private homes and
public spaces as Mike Armstrong explains
the anger and anxiety over the nasty
insects has sparked a political
crisis they may be small in size but bed
bugs are keeping exterminators more than
a little busy for this Paris company
home visits have jumped about
60% and in their shop about 80% of sales
are products for just one little
bug
he says the owner called them to this
apartment after going to a movie theater
and then finding a bed bug at home now
it's that going out part that has people
nervous social media is full of videos
of bed bugs found in theaters and trains
it's made it hard to sit just about
anywhere this woman says she was
stressed out going
out this woman says when she gets back
home she'll wash all her clothes we're
becoming paranoid she says well after
after signs of bed bugs were found at
this school Thursday 80 teachers walked
off the job exterminators are now set to
go in next
week bed bugs are a disaster this
teacher says there's no way we're
bringing them back to our
homes an opposition politician this week
called the situation a national public
health problem saying a wave of panic is
gripping the country so how big an issue
is it well the French health authority
says between 2017 and 2022 one in 10
French households was infested this
expert says the population of bed bugs
in the country is doubling every 5 years
so it it's rising quite slowly but at a
regular rate so it's quite concerning of
course now bed bugs aren't a hygiene
issue if they're found it's something
someone brought in they do feed on blood
and usually bite during the night they
can also be a mental health issue with
frustration and fear leading to
anxiety this exterminator says people
can fall into depression he has
customers who call in
tears now the two biggest factors for
this growing problem according to the
government are greater resistance to
insecticides and an increase in
tourism well with Paris hosting the
Olympics next summer tourism isn't
something that's going to slow down Mike
Armstrong Global
News ahead naming feelings the new
English term used to describe how people
are coping emotionally with the new
reality of the climate
[Music]
crisis the climate crisis is changing
the lives of many people in Canada and
really around the world devastating
fires floods and destruction this past
summer are prompting some experts to
refer to it as a summer of climate
reality so even if you weren't evacuated
waited or impacted you might know
someone who was this week on the new
reality we're looking into a fairly new
English term that may help us describe
how we feel as we witness the
environment irreversibly change around
us have you noticed a lot of changes in
the weather and the ice over your
lifetime this is what research can look
like for Ashley consolo her work
spanning decades focuses on how
environmental change fueled by the
climate crisis impacts our mental and
emotional health yes there's a lot of
changes but everybody knows it
especially in the last 2 or 3 years
everything is mixed up consolo had
hundreds of conversations often outside
in places people feel connected to
Nature when you see your home change or
when you see things um you know shifting
in ways that don't make sense or that
don't match or or that affect your
identity the pain the trauma the loss
the sadness the fear the worry about
future Generations all of that is is
interconnected Elder Jee crane is in her
mid90s a lifetime of lived experience on
the land Labrador is at the front lines
of the climate crisis it's one of the
fastest warming places anywhere in the
world the sea ice has declined or the
weather has changed or the animals have
moved people here for decades have been
experiencing what in other parts of the
world people are still thinking is a
future future impact indigenous
communities have been speaking about
feelings linked to environmental change
for a long time but it wasn't until 2018
when consolo and a colleague published a
paper using a new term in English to
describe it ecological grief whether
it's an individual animal whether it's
an ecosystem a habitat a body of water a
forest large scale climate shifts
anything that is is changing around us
that is causing an emotional reaction
particularly grief and while this grief
is normal in a healthy response finding
way to cope can be
challenging sometimes you do need other
types of supports and counseling support
is hugely important in these times of
Crisis having strong family and friend
networks having collectives of people
that understand what you're going
through and that want to make a
difference we grieve what we love and
the place we call home is changing like
I have felt more devastated this summer
than I have in a long time and
simultaneously more inspired and
motivated and you see what people love
and then what what they love is worth
fighting
for we'll take a deeper dive into the
ways people are coping with ecological
grief and what it means for our health
on the new reality tonight at
7:00 next we return to the violence
between Israeli forces and Hamas and the
Innocents caught in the
[Music]
crossfire what's happening in Israel and
Gaza is difficult to watch and in the
days and the weeks ahead there will be a
lot of analysis and reflection about how
Decades of fragile coexistence is
seemingly vanished whatever the
perceived justification on each side
it's the innocent lives being cut short
and those caught in the crosshairs which
is absolutely shattering mothers fathers
grandparents children wondering if their
lives will ever return to
normal no matter the
side no matter the religion images of
death and destruction display the
painful truth of a turning point amidst
conflict that has persisted for
generations with no end in sight this
resident of ashalon says we live in a
reality that is not
real it is not normal to raise children
like this says this Israeli mother in
her damaged
home the sentiment that knows no
border the trauma two-sided the yearning
for safety something Israeli and
Palestinian parents have in
[Music]
common in Gaza Palestinians flee their
homes in anticipation of Israeli
retaliation of course we're afraid says
this
woman thank you for watching global news
on this unprecedented day we leave you
tonight with the devastating images of
the reality on the ground in Israel and
Gaza right now as blood shed between
both sides reaches a terrifying new
stage in a war that's only just
[Music]
beginning